there was a teacher in seattle our pal
jason rants up in seattle found this one
there was a teacher up in seattle who
kicked
a child out of her classroom now her
virtual classroom because they don't
have
real classrooms kick the kid out for
saying that he admires donald trump the
teacher
was in a in a group chat with with his
students
and he said who is a role model who is
someone that you want to follow
and the kid said quote is a 10 year old
kid in tacoma
i admire donald j trump because he is
making america great again
and because he is the best president the
united states could ever ever have and
he built the wall so terrorists couldn't
come into the u.s
trump is the best person in the world
and that's why i admire him
this teacher kicked the child
out of the classroom for saying he
admires the president
the president who now just recovered
from the coronavirus and
showed us all strength the teacher once
the teacher kicked the kid out
the the kid's mother who was looking
over and seeing the screen
started to record it listen to this
whiny morally idiotic teacher
positive things and role models that we
should admire
again the example that was shared in the
chat
which i went ahead and erased for us was
not appropriate
right especially as that individual has
created so much division and hatred
between people
and specifically um spoken hatred
to many different individuals okay
so i do apologize for kicking out of the
conference
as i went ahead and adjusted our
settings but the settings
should be adjusted now um
the chat should be locked for today just
because i i realized that maybe that
question
wasn't clear enough so we'll go ahead
and
skip on that for today okay again
um that individual has spoken
hate to many individuals
and i don't think is um
an appropriate example for a role model
um
who did you say donald j trump and this
teacher
this little wuss this this sniveling
little teacher comes out and kicks the
kid out and he wouldn't even accept
responsibility for it
he says well and i went in and i
adjusted the settings and i'm sorry if
the student got kicked out or i adjusted
the settings and you can't say that you
like the president he's a mean guy he
hate the president
this is obviously a teacher who does not
understand the virtues of courage
the virtues of strength the virtue of
manliness harvey mansfield professor at
harvard
wrote a great book called manliness a
number of years ago about this
virtue the word virtue by the way
relates to manliness it comes from
the latin word veer which means man veer
ii
manliness but now we're told in our
culture that manliness is toxic
and we all need to be effeminate
and when when women are effeminate
that's a perfectly fine thing
but when men are it's not a fine thing
when
you know there's a difference in words
you say womanly
to refer to a woman and you say
woman-ish to refer
to a man who is being effeminate what's
the difference
one is positive one is negative one is
proper
the other is bizarre off-kilter and
that's what we're seeing here
we're being told that that manliness
itself
is toxic so is it any surprise that the
media react negatively
when the president shows some strength
but it turns out all those people are
completely wrong
it is important particularly in times of
trial particularly in times of danger
to show some strength and some duty and
some responsibility i'm sure trump
wanted nothing more than to go lie down
in the east wing of the white house
and fluff up a pillow and relax because
i'm sure he's not feeling very well
right now
but he came out anyway
because that is his responsibility
and sniveling teachers in the mainstream
media don't get it
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video